it's thursday the 25th of february
hoping for full marks the government
unveils plans for teacher assessments to
replace gcse and a level exam
this year but critics warn their lead to
grade
inflation bumps in the road map sky news
goes inside
warrington hospital where staff are
concerned about rising winter pressures
the road map comes with good news and
kind of makes us all very bit anxious
and a bit nervous as well
purely an accident police say there's no
evidence tiger woods was impaired by
drink or drugs at the time of the crash
that left him seriously injured
acting irresponsibly an nhs england boss
criticizes gwyneth paltrow
of her unusual methods of combating long
covered
and there will be drier brighter calmer
conditions for the rest of this week
still a little bit of rain in the
forecast
so i'll have all the details for you
later in the program
good morning well after last summer's
chaos caused by an algorithm
to produce exam results it was very much
a case of must do better
for the government with a levels and
gcses canceled this year
students will instead be graded by their
teachers
there will be optional test papers and
exam results will come
earlier than usual to allow more time
for appeals
but there are concerns that allowing
schools to award grades
could lead to great inflation education
correspondent laura bundock reports
how to replace exams fairly that's the
question
and now we know the government's answer
this year
the grades will be given by teachers
with so much missed
learning it's still a stressful time for
students
i'm quite concerned about how
my teachers will assess my grades
because some teachers i didn't have
last year and so i feel like that
opinion on me might be different
the idea of doing exams was much too
overwhelming after we'd missed so much
school and i was already so demotivated
i just don't think that personally i
could have sat an exam and got the grade
that i deserved
i think because there's no algorithm
it'll be definitely better
i myself feel that i trust my teachers
i've worked closely with them
over the last two years and i've tried
my best in exams
that algorithm caused chaos last summer
leaving many students downgraded even
missing places
at university it was eventually ditched
but the damage had already been done
here's what's happening this year
teachers will submit grades to exam
boards by june the 18th
students then find out results from the
9th of august
that's two weeks earlier than normal and
provides a period for students to appeal
ministers say their plan offers fairness
and flexibility
the problem last year was the system
wasn't fair and it led to a last-minute
u-turn
both of these things added huge stress
and anxiety to students
and that's something everyone wants to
avoid this time
the head teacher in this north london
school welcomes trust
being given to teachers because we know
our students
we can look at what evidence we need to
give them the best
possible grade to give them the best
possible chance
i think it overall i think it will work
well for teachers and it will work well
for young people
but there are still significant concerns
about the lack of detail
unions question the reliability and
consistency of grades
if schools use different methods they
think the government's made a serious
error of judgment
and others fear there remains a risk of
excessive grade inflation
which could devalue the credibility of
this year's results laura bundock sky
news
well i'm joined now by the schools
minister nick gibb
so a big day for students they finally
got none so they've waited seven weeks
after being told their exams were
cancelled
and so how's this going to work
well the teacher will be the will devise
the grade it's teacher assessed grades
uh the teacher will look at array of a
range of evidence of the
students work over the last two years
there'll be quality assurance processes
in place
in the school the grades will be signed
off by the head teacher they'll be
submitted to the
exam boards on the 18th of june uh
there'll be quality assurance
processes in place by the exam boards
they'll have a
sample of schools they'll go and check
those grades to make sure there is the
evidence that supports them
and they'll be a risk-based uh sampling
as well
and the results will be announced on
august the 10th for a levels and august
the
12th for gcses and their and their
equivalents
and they'll be a very robust appeal
process for those students that are not
happy with their grades but we
that given that students will know the
the type of evidence that the
teacher will be using on which to base
their grade
uh any we hope that any uh problems will
have been resolved as a school level
a long time before the grades have
submitted
let me read you a quote by doing away
with all moderation it would be
misguided and create deep inequalities
without moderation there would be great
inflation of 12
percentage points at aced rna casting
doubt on the validity of the grades in
the eyes of employers and
university that was yourself a year ago
saying exactly that that this new system
would lead to great equal inequalities
well we do think that exams are the
fairest system and we were determined to
keep exams but when it became very clear
in january that we were restricting
access to schools tall but the
vulnerable children and
children of critical workers given the
disruption that students had faced
over the year uh the only fair system
was to move away from exam this year
to a teacher assess system and we have
built in very protective measures
we trust the judgments of professionals
who run our schools
uh but on top of that we have these
quality assurance processes
to make sure that there is a process at
the school level uh to ensure that the
the grades are a fair reflection of the
attainment of the students and then
there's that other
quality assurance by the examples
there's also very detailed
guidance that's uh produce will be
produced by the examples and detailed
training
for teachers in how to submit those
exams so there's a whole
raft of measures to make sure that uh
the grades are
are a fair reflection of the work and
the ability of students
but but if you're saying that exams are
the best thing are you basically saying
that this plan
is the best of a bad bunch i'm saying
it's the best we can do
other than exams and exams this year
wouldn't be fair because of the
different levels of disruption that
students have faced across the country
so this is the best system
and we trust the professionalism of
teachers and head teachers
we consulted very widely on the 15th of
january for two weeks
on the basis of these details and and
100 000
responses half of whom were students
uh the these this method has achieved
widespread support in the sector
including from the
the heads of some of the big unions jeff
barton and so on uh
has been very supportive of these
measures we've worked very closely
uh with the with the with the schools
with the regulator with the exam boards
um to make sure that we we put together
the best possible method of ensuring
fairness
and to ensure that students can move on
to the next phase of their life we don't
want any student
to suffer long-term damage to their
prospects as a consequence of this
pandemic
but but you're saying it it is
essentially a compromise it's not what
you would like to do
you're putting all your faith in the
hands of the teachers but you didn't
want to do that
last year i wonder what's changed you
know have you suddenly had a revelation
that teachers are quite capable of
monitoring their own pupils
well we put in place as i said these
quality assurance
processes and with very detailed
guidance from examples to make sure
teachers
sorry but you're essentially asking
teachers not only to judge their pupils
but you're asking them to judge their
pupils against other schools and against
the rest of the country how on earth can
can teachers be expected to do that
well teacher's very experienced and they
will know from
from from previous years uh what the
standard that a particular student has
reached given the disruption that they
have faced they will only look at
uh the work where that element of the
curriculum has actually been
taught there are those quality assurance
processes in place at the school level
and there'll be very detailed guidance
from examples about how to judge that
how to judge students and how to create
that range of evidence to support
the grades that have been it seems like
last year you were saying we can't trust
teachers it must be an exam
and teachers words were totally ignored
when it came to saying look this this
people is perfectly capable of getting
this grade and
and you've awarded them a much lower
grade and now it seems you're saying
right teachers are going to have all the
responsibility and quite frankly
if it gets messed up this year we can
blame them
no look you know one learns from uh
what happened in pre last year
and we've worked very closely for many
months
even even when the schools were open and
we were expecting exams to go ahead we
were working on a contingency
in case we had to cancel exams because
of further disruption
to children's education we've worked
closely with the examples we've worked
closely with the school sector with
teachers head teachers
every step of the way we've consulted uh
to make sure
that that we can we can devise a system
that's as fair as possible for students
they can move on to the next stage of
their lives
but but you're right of course exams are
the fairest and best system of judging
attainment but we can't have exams this
year because of the pandemic and because
of the
the disruption that many students have
faced up and down the country
it wouldn't be fair to hold exams this
year and we trust professional teachers
are the people that know their students
best
and we do trust their professionalism
and we can make sure they're stupid
but academics are questioning this
system natalie pereira from the
education policy institute says there's
a really high risk
we'll see inconsistencies in the grades
among different pupils and schools
and a significant risk that schools will
take very different approaches to
grading it could result in large
numbers of pupils appealing their grades
or extremely high grade inflation it's
going to lead to chaos in the summer
again isn't it
no um all these risks that uh the epi is
talking about and
are all risk we're all fully aware of of
course this is not
the ideal situation to be in this is a
consequence of the pandemic
but it is the fairest system given the
different levels of disruption students
have faced and of course we are aware of
all those issues
that think tanks and other people that
down over the last the last year
repeatedly
and you're now telling them well look
you've got to go through jump through
these hoops
it's not ideal but it's the best we can
come up with and it's taken us seven
weeks to come up with it
well we were working on this before
christmas
we were able once schools were announced
that schools were not going to be open
to most students on the 4th of january
we were ready to consult
with the details of this on the 15th of
january so we've been very
prepared for being working on this for
many months it is the it is the fairy
system
we want to make sure that students
continue to study so the exam
grades won't be submitted until the 18th
of june that gives more months
of the face-to-face teaching as schools
are going back on the 8th of march
we want to do everything we can to help
students
deal with the consequences of this
pandemic the pandemic
has caused all kinds of disruption to
children's education that's what's
driven this
and what we're doing as a government is
trying to make up for that
by a the all the measures we announced
yesterday about
the catch up the recovery premium and
that builds on all the catch-up funding
the billion pounds that we announced
earlier this year and and the one-to-one
tuition and so on
we want to make sure that no pupil no
student
suffers long-term damage to their
prospects as a consequence of this
pandemic
and one of the things we need to do is
to make sure
that they get grades they get their
qualifications this year so they can
move on to
college to university to an
apprenticeship and not have that process
that
uh progress disrupted by this pandemic
and that's what this
uh system does it's the fairer system
that we could devise
working we've worked very closely with
teachers and with the education sector
in devising it
it's had widespread support when we
consulted including
50 000 students who've responded to the
consultation john cole's
from off call i don't know if you've
heard the reports uh this morning that
he has resigned
can you confirm that well he resigned a
little while ago
when one of the committees that he was
on was going to be uh was no longer
needed
look i respect sir john coles very much
indeed he runs in
an effective multi-academy trust and he
has his quote
he said the government is desperate
our viewers might not though that the
government's desperate not to be accused
of having an algorithm or exams by the
back door
uh focusing on this rather than the
actual goal how are we going to be fair
to young people we risk an outcome in
august much
worse than last year what do you make of
that
so he so he thought that the exam
materials that were
that were making available to teachers
the question banks that they can use as
part of the the range of evidence that
they'll need to supply two examples
about
how they've devised the grade he wanted
that to be
compulsory mandatory we asked that
question in the consultation should
should those materials should they be an
option for teachers or should they be
mandatory
and the consultation was very clear that
they should be an option and not
mandatory we didn't want
those materials to be regarded as a mini
exam
because you know we've cancelled exams
this year because they were felt to be
unfair
uh given the disruption so we didn't
want to then cancel exams and replace
them with another exam
but that you know john isn't entitled
his views but the majority of people in
the sector including the heads of the
major unions such as ascal believe that
we have devised
the best possible method given the
circumstances it's
fair there are quality assurances and
checks to make sure that those grades do
reflect the work
of the students they'll be a robust
appeal process
and we've got an awesome season series
in case students are not happy they can
take the exams in the autumn
if they wish to do so you mentioned the
summer schools
who who are going to run these because
the teachers as well as now having to
learn a whole new system
and mark all these exam papers have been
teaching some students at school
some online they are quite frankly
knackered
who on earth is going to run these
summer schools
well we want them run from the schools
um and but but there's
the reason why there's funding is to
enable the schools to be able to
employ people to run to take part and
run those summer schools we want a
summer of activities to
who is qualified to teach our youngsters
apart from teachers
well there are a whole raft of people
that will be able to come in
young graduates should teach people who
are training to be teachers retired
teachers
that's a matter for the school to decide
but we are providing uh
200 million pounds to enable schools to
run those summer schools and that's on
top of all the other measures
uh the billion pounds we've distributed
to schools uh to provide
catch up the the the the national
tutoring program 33 tutoring companies
i have a few seconds left but how are
you going to ensure that the right
people the right children get this and
it's not just the parents with the
sharpest elbows
that it's actually the children who've
missed out uh who actually get this help
now we're giving guidance to schools to
focus uh
these resources to students the most
disadvantaged students
who have suffered the most during the
pandemic to help them to catch up
there's a whole raft of measures as i've
said the national tutoring program the
academic mentors
the premiums that we've given to schools
to help
to fund this we've also appointed sir
kevin collins to look at for
slightly longer term about how we can
ensure that students that need
you know that need to catch up over a
period of months and years
that we have measures in place for those
students as well and we'll be
we'll be listening to what sir kevin has
to say about how we can do that
we are determined that no student will
suffer that
long-term damage to their prospects as a
consequence of this pandemic
and we're backing that determination
with 1.7 billion pounds over this period
to make sure that
that every student will be able to catch
up and today's announcement about how
we're going to make sure every young
person has their qualification despite
the fact we've had the cancer exams
it's a fair system and it does mean
they'll be able to go on to the next
phase of their
of their career nick we're going to have
to leave you there thank you very much
for joining us this morning thank you
very much
well let's bring in now our political
correspondent rob powell who is here
with us and
rob so really an acknowledgement from
him that it's it's not the best system
in the world
it's it's kind of the best they can come
up with for this year yeah i think the
government is in a very
tricky position here and whatever they
came up with i think there would be
it wouldn't be perfect and there would
be downsides to it i think the worry
with the system that's come up with
which focuses very heavily on
teacher assessed grades rather than any
process of standardization i think the
worry will be that they've yo-yoed from
one position last year of using this
algorithm to try and
standardize grades across the country
and get consistency
and they've gone to the other extreme
and whilst they may have solved some of
the problems caused by that algorithm
they may have created other problems
because teachers even with
their grades being standardized within
the school will inevitably judge
progress
differently to other schools so how how
do you compare one people from one
school
to another people from another school if
you don't have some system
then i'm nick gibb they're saying that
there would be robust quality assurance
processes
um as he put it i think we will have to
see more detail of how robust
those processes are going are going to
be also interesting i think confirming
that sir john coles who sat on a board
at off coli
off quality exam regulator did resign
because he felt that some exam materials
that are being made
optional for teachers to use their
assessments he felt that they should
have been mandatory to get some kind of
whole country standardization
the government chose not to do that and
as a result he stepped down
rob thanks very much well
moving away from education more evidence
that the pandemic is causing fewer
people to come
forward to get cancer systems symptoms
checked we're going to speak
to two patients at half past eight
also more on the government's new plan
for assessing pupils just after half
past seven we are going to speak to a
former chief examiner and
a current a level student
and later in the program i'm going to be
speaking to a north yorkshire surfer
who's been
reunited with his beloved board that was
picked up
400 miles away in the shetland islands
now the crisis in hospitals is not over
yet that's the warning from doctors
facing a new wave of patients which is
putting the nhs
under renewed strain the announcement of
the roadmap for lifting the lockdown
has coincided with an increase in people
going to hospital
some with covert but many now with
complaints usually associated with the
winter season
our health correspondent ashish joshi
reports so we've got four ambulances on
the way in now so there's two inbound
and two expected and one's just arrived
they weathered the first and the second
wave
now they're bracing themselves for the
cold wave
seasonal winter pressure it's late
but it's here i think where we are now
um february going into march this would
probably have come a little bit earlier
we're starting to see what we would say
is our winter pressures
the last week or two rather than it
start in january
so i think it's a little bit later and i
think the next couple of weeks are going
to be very challenging
the news of the road map comes with with
good news and
kind of makes us all very bit anxious
and a bit nervous as well
it's a triple whammy winter sick
patients who have stayed away from
hospital
are now seeking treatment and there's
still a pandemic
hi debbie debbie fairbrother was rushed
to hospital
by ambulance after she fainted at work
her daily blackout started after she
caught covered 19
five weeks ago what happened to you
as far as i know i just collapsed
[Music]
much to be honest i just remember waking
up and then
the hospital is seeing a sharp spike in
emergency attendances
we've been here for nearly 48 hours and
at least
392 patients have attended
a d in that time that's comparable
to the busiest winter we've been filming
here for about 10 minutes and in that
time
about four ambulances have arrived now
that just gives you
an idea of just how much pressure there
is still
on hospitals like this one
the hospital's intensive care units are
still full of very sick covid19 patients
but thankfully there are fewer now than
during the peak of the second wave
i think at some point lockdown has got
to be eased
you know the government's in an
impossible situation when do you do it
numbers are certainly dropping the
pressure is
certainly easing on the nhs and we're
starting to see more of the normal
winter pressure
we wouldn't be surprised if there wasn't
another another surge under the wave
hospitals across the country must manage
winter pressures
at the same time as covid19
infection control hot and cold zones
and patient flows new ways of working
must be found cardiac monitoring
everything's in there
dr patel showed me the new pods where he
can treat
and still protect vulnerable patients
this area has been remodeled to take
pressure
off its emergency department you're
noticing the normal
copd asthma patients coming through the
door now
that we perhaps didn't do a little while
ago
and that presents another challenge
because we need to protect those that
have come in with
frail lung conditions from any other
patients that may have covered within
the hospital
so it's about creating areas like this
to like you say
mean that we've got a place to move them
out of a e as quickly as possible
it's right to look forward to the summer
the vaccines and falling
infection rates give us hope but it's
also wrong to think this emergency
is over ashish joshi sky news
at warrington hospital
time for a look at the morning's other
main stories now and facebook says it's
banned the myanmar military from
using its facebook and instagram
platforms
as pro-democracy demonstrators continue
to protest the military coup
the army seized power earlier this month
making unsubstantiated claims of fraud
in last november's election which was
won by aung suchi's national league
for democracy
sky news has been recognised with six
awards at this year's royal television
society journalism awards including
news channel of the year the channel
also scooped best home and
international coverage for its reporting
of the pandemic both here
and in europe and in italy's epicenter
in bergamo nick martin
was jane's specialist journalist of the
year for revealing the human cost of
coronavirus
in care homes and the outstanding
contribution award went to the head
of sky news john riley
the actress gwyneth paltrow says she is
suffering from long covert which left
her with fatigue and brain
fog but her methods to tackle the
syndrome have been criticized by the
national medical director for nhs
england
professor stephen powers uh well let's
bring in hanisha sethi who has more for
us
please tell us this doesn't involve
candles tanisha well gwyneth paltrow is
known for her health hacks whether
that's bee sting facials
or goat milk cleanses she loves sharing
her health hacks
online now like many other celebrities
that
caught covid she's been suffering from
long-covered symptoms including
brain fog like you just mentioned and
she's been sharing some of her remedies
online
now these include drinking herbal
non-alcoholic cocktails
using an infrared sauna which is just a
modern type of sauna for you and i
and she's also keen on using a keto and
plant-based diet
which involves fasting up until 11am
every day
now gwyneth paltrow on her own instagram
account has a large following of 7.4
million followers so her reach is huge
and this is kind of where the problem
lies
because being in the public eye and
having a huge following
people are quick to criticize especially
when it comes to public health issues
now this is where the nhs has stepped in
because professor stephen powis
has said that serious science should be
applied
like the virus misinformation carries
across
borders and he goes on to say that some
of the solutions that she's recommending
are not solutions we would recommend in
the nhs and he goes on to wish her well
but there is a wider issue here which is
collective responsibility
not just for individuals but celebrities
alike
initiate thank you very much
well let's get a look at the weather now
naz
i'm not going to ask you about your
alternative remedies but how is the
weather going to be treating us
throughout the rest of the day
my alternative remedy jane is plenty of
sunshine and that's what we're looking
at for today it's sunny skies for
most places but there is a little bit of
rain in the forecast
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we're looking at mostly
fine and settled conditions across a
vast majority of the uk and the island
for today and for the rest of the week
it's going to become
much drier and calmer there is still a
bit of wet weather around though for
today in fact
this morning across many central
southern and eastern parts of
england we are seeing cloudy skies this
morning some patchy outbreaks of rain
the rest of england and
wales mainly dry and sunny and plenty of
sunshine elsewhere in fact
but it is a bit of a cool and fresher
start to the day compared to recently
with a frost in some rural spots and
there are blustery showers across the
northwest of scotland
showers will continue across scotland
through this afternoon becoming more
widespread across the north there then
eventually easing a bit
a few showers across ireland and
northern ireland mainly dry the england
worlds but east anglian southeast cloudy
and damp
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
thanks nas still to come on sky news
breakfast we're going to be getting more
on the government's new plans for gcse
and a levels this year
we'll speak to a former chief examiner
and a current a-level student
[Music]
so
[Music]
um it contains all kinds of treasures
that
um the darwin children collected so
there's for example
a uh silk handkerchief that belonged to
charles darwin
um letters lots of locks of family hair
and um little pencils carved animals
and most significantly this collection
of shells
um many of which were collected by
charles darwin on the beagle voyage
well charles darwin um traveled around
the world on hms beagle between 1831 and
1836
and the point of the voyage was to map
areas of land
and sea that had not previously been um
recorded
and it was a very formative time for
charles darwin the observations that he
made on the beagle voyage
ultimately went on to allow him to
develop his theory of evolution
he collected many specimens on the
beagle voyage um which all
fed into his work on evolution that he
developed at down house
and so the this little collection of
shells really um
highlight some of the things that he was
he was looking for on the voyage some of
the things that he brought back
but i think it's just really wonderful
that he then gave those to his daughters
for their little shell collection
i don't think there can be many
victorian children who could have
claimed to have had
shelves from the south pacific in their
keepsake box
[Music]
for the early
for the knowledge risers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
but wherever you are welcome to safety
ridgewood
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free let's say with our top story
this morning the school's minister nick
gibb says the plan to replace a-level
and gcse exams
with teacher-assessed grades this year
is the fairest system possible saying
that the government
has learned from last summer's
controversy when an algorithm downgraded
the results of thousands of students
here's what he told us a little earlier
this hour
one learns from uh what happened in
pre-last year
and we've worked very closely for many
months
even even when the schools were open and
we were expecting exams to go ahead we
were working on a contingency
in case we had to cancel exams because
of further disruption
uh to children's education we've worked
closely with examples we've worked
closely with the school sector with
teachers head teachers
every step of the way we've consulted to
make sure
that that we can we can divide a system
that's as fair as possible for students
they can move on to the next stage of
their lives
but but you're right of course exams are
the fairest and best system of judging
attainment
but we can't have exams this year
because of the pandemic and because of
the
the disruption that many students have
faced up and down the country
it wouldn't be fair to hold exams this
year and we trust professional teachers
are the people that know
their students best and we do trust
their professionalism
well let's get more on how these
government plans for teacher assessments
will be used
in place of gcse and a levels this year
i'm joined by john niels a former chief
examiner for the exam board aqa
um lovely to talk to you john what are
your initial thoughts about the plans
i think the governments are just washing
the hands of the whole thing
just putting in the hands of teachers
and expecting the teachers
with no training to get on with this
and accept they'll take all the flack
from parents
and it's the parents what i call the
geography parents the ones with the
peninsula units and the islands and the
granite
outcrops in the kitchens they'll be the
ones we'll be pushing for higher grades
it's the ones the students who are all
who were going to get the levels one to
three they're going to be the ones who
are going to suffer
i had a meeting i was part of a meeting
with some other educationists on may the
12th last year
where we offered off qual via
a teams meeting we offered off qual a
system
a con a continuous assessment a system
that included examinations
that enable teachers to gather evidence
to keep the evidence to have criterion
referenced work
to back up a grade we offered that to
off qual
nearly a year ago we're still waiting
for a response
this isn't the first day there was one
in 2012
as well this has been going on for years
i disagree with nick gibb
exams are not the fairest means of
assessment he did say that that teachers
will be looking at how the the pupils
have performed over the year
and that there will be a form of
comparison that that
the exam boards will be going into some
schools to try and make sure that they
are fair i mean do you
it isn't an ideal system clearly he
acknowledged as much
but do you think it it is perhaps fairer
than making them
sit full-blown exams absolutely
the the exams are not going to happen
but there has to be
and there's been a chance there's been a
year of this going on
there's been an opportunity to involve
year 11 students year 10 students and
say look
we need a portfolio of evidence
everybody's
portfolio has got to be the same how are
you going to compare
one portfolio of evidence for one school
with another portfolio of evidence to
another school
some students have gone feral they
haven't been in school
they haven't got that work to to compare
how are you going to give a grade to
someone who hasn't got that work
if everybody had the same system if
there was a
an online system a way of recording what
students work from the age of 11 all the
way through till they're 16 because in
the real world
students don't always perform best on
one particular
day when they're 16 sometimes they do it
when they're 12 or 13.
catch that catch that success
catch that work store it
use it against criteria and say this
student can do this
let's see where we can get them let's
not stop at gcse when the 16
let's go to undergraduate level at 16.
let's make let's make this an
opportunity to do something about the
educational system
at the moment it's not working the
teachers
the schools are the ones are going to be
taking this in the net
without any help from the government at
all
so do you feel that the system that has
been proposed for this year
i mean we could talk endlessly about the
the catastrophe of last year
but do you think the system for this
year is going to increase
inequalities between those who perhaps
have have the least resources
in society the least backup at home and
those as you say
the geography parents with the granite
worktops
yes absolutely yes they're the ones that
are going to suffer
but all students are going to suffer the
last people we want it to suffer
to suffer in this other students they're
the ones who've gone through this
they've missed out on social life
they've missed out on educational um
attainment achievement mixing with
friends they've missed out on all of
these things and it's the ones who were
the
levels one to three that thirty percent
the rump of the educated the one the
kids that you love
they're the ones who are going to suffer
they're the ones who are going to lose
out in this situation
and they're the ones who have got very
different things to offer society that
we absolutely need
john nield former chief examiner
interesting to talk to you thank you
let's talk now to a student uh charlie
knott who is an
a level student and is joining us now hi
charlie and what are your thoughts about
what you've heard from the government
about what they are proposing for this
summer
for you i mean it's interesting because
it probably won't come as a surprise to
anyone but we've been very confused and
a little frustrated
for quite a while now but i think the
thing i want to get across about what's
just come out
is that they've we're still confused but
just in a different way now because
we're not
sure whether the way that our grades are
going to be determined is fair or not
because i think the main the worry and
the underlying problem of the new system
is that it's not representative of
comparing two people in different parts
of the country
and the teachers are only going to have
the data to compare two people
in the same school so you could have
someone that outperforms
70 of the country but because they're
one of the worst in their class
will be given a lower grade than they
would have done in a natural exam
i think that's what's going to worry
people the most
is whether their teachers will have
enough evidence to go on or
like good enough representation of how
hard they've worked to give them a grade
which represents their ability
i mean would you have preferred exams or
do you think exams would have been
a pretty challenging this year given
what you've gone through
i think i probably don't speak for
everyone when i say this for me
personally i would have preferred exams
but only because
that probably would have given me an
advantage i can see that
because of the lack of resources that
some people will have
sitting exam this year would have been
unbelievably unfair
but i do think what we need from
exam boards which i think they may be
offering schools is some sort of
standardized
material that they can assess students
on because they have to have a way
of comparing students between schools
otherwise if you're an employer or a
university looking to admit a student
and they have an a you don't know
whether that's them being better than
most of the country or them being better
than most of their college
and that means that any a level given
any grade given from 2021
is just going to be seen as a terrible
representation of a student's ability
charlie what are you studying what are
you hoping to do and what are the last
couple of years been like
for you i'm studying physics
maths and economics and i'm hoping to go
on to the engineering
um so i've got some quite challenging
offers it's important to me that
i do really well and again i i think the
best thing for me
would just to be tested on the stuff
i've learned because
i feel confident with it i think if i
was tested i would do better
than if my teachers just let me do my
thing i think there'll be a lot of
students
in the country a bit like me who like to
sort of just you know pull out the bag
at the last minute
and there is going to be a big worry
that's a perfectly fine thing to do when
it comes to a-level exams people do it
every year
you do a whole load of revision just
before you go ahead do well in the exam
and you get the results you need
if you think about it this year for
every for quite a significant chunk of
people that will be doing that
it's going to go horribly wrong for them
because they haven't been doing that
well
all year and they'll be even a much
lower grade than they deserve if they
had put the work in
i mean you're obviously pretty diligent
but how how hard has it been to stay
focused
oh i mean it's not easy we have
two hour lessons with you know upwards
of 200 people in them
and if you think about you have one
teacher which you know i can sympathize
for the teachers that must be a
nightmare for them too but it is hard
if you're asking a question if several
people are asking questions at once just
like
in a little chat box down the side it's
it's hard to get
instant feedback it's also hard with
marking because marking online is a pain
because we have to scan all our work in
and they can't just write on the paper
it makes it really hard
which means that quite a lot of the
marking we're having to do ourselves
which means it's a lot harder to get
feedback on your work
well charlie don't despair all that work
you've done it will have gone into the
gray matter it will be useful in the
long run even if you're not being tested
on it
well done and thanks so much for talking
to us this morning on sky
now police say the car crash which
injured tiger woods
was purely an accident with no evidence
that the golf star was impaired by drugs
or
alcohol he's recovering in hospital
after surgery on serious injuries
to his right leg the first officer on
the scene said the 45 year old
was not aware how badly injured he was
from los angeles
sally lockwood reports those who pulled
tiger woods from this crash
say he's lucky to be alive but it's
unclear if his injuries
could force an end to the golfer's
sporting career
police are calling this an accident not
a crime
the first officer to arrive at the scene
found no evidence that golfer was
intoxicated
or impaired but says woods appeared
unaware
of the gravity of his condition i asked
him you know
hey can you tell me your first name um
he looked at me and he said tiger
and it took me a half second but
i saw his face and i and i thought oh
yeah you're tiger woods i don't think he
was aware of
how gravely he was injured at the time
tiger woods was rescued through the
windscreen
the exterior of the suv severely
battered
after it rolled several times the
protected interior
and seat belt is credited with saving
the golfer's life
this section of road is said to be
notorious for accidents
and tiger woods it's understood was
driving downhill at speed
when his suv lost control his injuries
were said to be so
serious no impairment tests were done at
the scene
as he was rushed to a trauma center for
emergency surgery
we've learned a metal rod has been put
in the golfer's injured right leg
and screws and pins are reinforcing his
ankle and foot
now in recovery the long-term impact of
these injuries
is still unknown the muscles they have
to get strong
we have to work on coordination so he's
in a machine
that's a finely tuned machine and so
it's the muscles
and the rotation of the body parts and
the creation of momentum
these are all the things that allow him
to do what he does so that's going to
take a much longer time than just
six to eight weeks for the bones to heal
tiger woods come back from rock bottom
with a masters win in 2019
has been described as something from a
film
many don't want this crash to be the
scene that ends his sporting career
without tiger woods out there i think
something would be lacking i think that
most golfers after a couple of back
surgeries would have said you know what
i'm done with this i can't do it anymore
but yet he's got four of them and then
now he's got this latest set back with
this accident
if there's any individual in the world
that can come back from this it's
certainly tiger
it's unclear how long the golfer will
remain in hospital
or if he'll ever play again but one
thing many know
is a comeback should never be discounted
for tiger woods
sally lockwood sky news los angeles
still to gun on sky news breakfast i'm
going to be speaking to the shadow
communities and
local government secretary steve reed
about how labour plans to secure the
future
of britain's post-pandemic high streets
i'm diana magnay and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
[Music]
please just make their first move and
they're bothering firing together
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
[Music]
that's what's left of the north tunnel
uh where the north koreans exploded five
nuclear warheads and this is a show of
strength
at a time when china is more fragile
than it has been at any time in recent
years
shrapnel from that explosion you can see
it littered along
all the way we take you to the heart of
the stories that shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports
that they are being blocked by police so
we're going to try and find a way out
after five days stranded here this is
deliverance
we help you understand the world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
[Music]
so
the labour party's unveiling plans for
how it says it would secure the future
of britain's high streets after the
pandemic
among proposals are reversing new
planning rules by
introduced by the conservatives and also
giving councils new power
to repurpose commercial properties that
have been vacant for at least
12 months well i'm joined now by steve
reid who's the shadow communities and
local government
secretary and see we will very much come
on to high street
um and uh what what you're hoping from
the budget but but first let's just
quickly get your thoughts on that on the
big story of the day exams
uh we are now at least being given some
certainty for pupils do you welcome
today's announcement by the government
yes on exams it's after the chaos that
we saw
last year with the algorithm um you know
i'm we're really glad that the
government has decided not to go back
to that i went and visited you know
several groups of students at their
schools
last year and they were absolutely
terrified about their future prospects
after the algorithm downgraded the
results that everybody expected them to
get many of them
lost their university places so yes it's
welcome that we'll be
seeing teachers given a much bigger say
this time but we do want to make sure
there are measures in place to ensure
that there's consistency
across the whole piece and that there
will be a system for reviewing and
checking
to make sure that the grades being
awarded to students are the right grades
for students who aren't being tested or
examined at the end of this term
uh for those going on there are going to
be summer schools to help them catch up
uh do you think the teaching unions will
oppose teachers getting involved with
this
no of course they won't because you know
teachers have already been going way
beyond the extra mile to to help
helps students in schools up and down
the country over this past year
i mean and the additional funding the
government's announced is welcome of
course we've got a whole generation here
that's missed out on their education
it's going to take much more frankly
than one summer
to help them to catch up so the
additional funding is welcome
but if you really look at how much is
being put in it works out
only 43 p per pupil per day
and it's going to take a lot more than
that to see a whole generation of
students
catch up so while this is a a good start
it's nowhere near enough we really need
a
a major national program running over
several years to ensure that an entire
generation of young people
can catch up with the education that
will really mark whether they can or
can't make the most
of their futures and we should see this
as an investment in the future by the
way because that's what invest
education is for the young people who
are receiving education but for all of
us
we need a well-educated population if we
want to succeed
as a country i mean do you not feel that
the government is just passing the buck
onto the teachers that they've
given them all the responsibility yes
they're giving them money but
they are essentially saying you know any
any more problems you're going to be the
ones that cop it
well this is this is why we need a
national programme this is a start but
it's nowhere near enough
what the government's announced here
you've got to pay catch up with young
people a generation of young people have
lost out on a year
of education now you can't catch up on
that just with some summer schools
over this summer this has to go on for
much longer than that and the amount of
funding
that the government's come forward with
it's the equivalent of one new trainee
teacher
over a whole year for a secondary school
that won't be enough it's a start but we
really need the government to to look at
this situation
talk to parents and families and
children but also the education
profession
to look at how we really do step up to
the markers country
because what the government's announced
so far won't do the uh the full job
uh onto high streets then um they have
really suffered
during the pandemic but you know they've
been suffering for quite a while haven't
they
uh all the other labour party a little
bit late to the party here um
you know are they are they savable the
high streets quite frankly
well i i don't think anyone wants us to
write
off our high streets right now that high
streets are going through
uh a situation they've never faced
before many of our shops
businesses hospitality spaces have been
closed for the better part
of a year now they're really on on their
last legs financially
but we need to support our high streets
to recover
and to survive from this now of course
there have been changes that have been
underway for a long time particularly
the shift from bricks and mortar retail
to
online retail but it's really speeded up
over the last year i think one-third
of shopping now has shifted from bricks
and mortar to
to online but we still don't have a
level playing field between
shops and uh and shopping on on the
internet for instance many you know the
shops in my constituency tell me
they can't compete on on equal terms
because they're having to pay a high
level of business rates
under normal times whereas the online
retailers don't
so we've been calling for years now for
the government to look at leveling the
playing field
on rates between online retailers and
bricks and mortar shops and our high
streets so that they can
compete on more equal terms because none
of us
can afford to see or would want to see
our high streets hollowed out
and never recover they're a vital one
community and we need to support
everything indeed why then is the labour
party not
uh supporting an increase in corporation
tax kistama yesterday in the commons now
is not the time for tax rises on
families and businesses
i mean that would be a really simple way
of taxing these big corporations who as
you say have made an absolute killing
during the pandemic
well i think kirsten was absolutely
right to say
what he said it's about timing this no
one's saying that labour wouldn't look
at the need to increase taxation
you know it's we someone's got to pay
for this pandemic that the country
has has spent so much money wouldn't now
be the time to tax the big corporations
like amazon
who have made so much money out of it
there will come a time to do that but
the problem is if you increase taxes
right now on families and businesses you
run the risk
of choking off the economic recovery and
that means losing jobs and people losing
their incomes
and if you do that you slow the economic
recovery down you can even
throw it into reverse we've just come
through the worst recession of
any major economy in this country
because over the last decade this
government has weakened
the foundations of our economy we can't
afford
to run risk risks with people's jobs at
a time like this
jobs and protecting people's jobs should
be the focus of all of us right now
in trying to help people get through
this and it's not just corporations
actually the government's looking at
looking at they're also putting up
council tax on families
this april it's the wrong thing to do
okay we're going to have to leave it
there
steve reed thanks very much for joining
us today on sky thank you